يبقى باستثناء ما يبدو لي مع
ملون بدلاً من سؤال الضرائب أو أنت
في مثل هذه القضايا ، الآن سأشرح شيئًا ما
يبدو لي أنه لا يبدو أنني آخذها فقط
من الواضح تماما عمل الاستفزاز
اطلب في البار ما يريدون عرضه عليهم
يمكن أن veliara ثنائية فقط
الليلة البريطانية مختلفة ونحن شخصان
لأنه يفهم ذلك
قداس بريت حقيقي من اندفاعة لدينا
المياه هناك الناس من العالم تفكيك ريكى
لقد تم إبلاغي بهذا بالطبع في أونتاريو
أفلام مثل إرادة جيش دمبلدور
ذاكرة
استيراد عدد 4 التهرب 32 ماذا
قوى القمع
لا أستطيع أن أعتقد أنه حيث لدينا
يتحول إلى وقت الغليان إيم ثانية
الحديث عن سياسي اجتماعي
غاب عن خطة قبل أيام قليلة
اجتماعات في جنيف الجليدية
يجب أن يولد نبي أو واحد بشرف
إذا لم يكن هناك ازدراء
الاختيار ، ولكن في روسيا لا يوجد شيء من هذا القبيل
ربما في منظمة حلف شمال الأطلسي نحن منزعج من العقيدة
كان الجميع الآن هو طالب دراسات عليا
جمع العسل الهولندي نعم سوف تأخذ في
هذا يعني الجليد من نواح كثيرة ، حتى لو كان هنا
كان العالم على حافة الهاوية ، لذلك لا أعتقد ذلك
سنكون سعداء أنه لا يوجد حتى من
ثم لا ، أنا أردد على نظرة صديقي
في روس جلبت ضجيج طالبان لأن
أمضينا
كبير
35 إنهاء بهدوء هؤلاء الرجال
بدلا من ذلك فعلوا استياءنا
لا تكرر الخطاف على طبق أو
يهاجم آخر
جميلة الشرب الأراضي الأوكرانية
على الجانب الآخر قد تكون عسكرية
قواعد في بلدان الإقليم الذي
مباشرة في روسيا ، ولكن هذا بطيخ
الأسباب